à
[Musique]
tour de contrôle a régné
ça lui coûte vitesse du vent faible
jean électrique maximale parachute et
pas les permissions décoller ce n'est
pas de la fiction
les araignées dépourvu d'elle peuvent
s'envoler atteindre des milliers de
mètres d'altitude et franchir des
centaines de kilomètres avant de se
poser grâce à deux études publiées cet
été
on comprend un peu mieux comment le
chercheur allemand moon son show
s'intéressent aux aspects aérodynamique
du vol au point d'étudier ces araignées
en soufflerie
quand le vent est suffisamment d'où elle
laisse filer un bouquet de petites soit
une sorte de parachute triangulaire qui
leur sert à décoller en recueillant les
fils au vol on constate qu'il y en a une
cinquantaine ses fils long de plusieurs
mètres sont extrêmement fins mille fois
plus mince qu'un cheveu humain
on a aussi découvert 40 s'envole et
l'araignée fixe deux fils beaucoup plus
gros une ligne de vie aucun sou mais le
vent n'explique pas tout depuis
longtemps on soupçonne qu'il ya une
deuxième force en jeu l'électricité
le principe c'est qu'il s'accumule
décharge électrique à la base des nuages
ce qui crée une différence de potentiel
avec le sol
[Musique]
le bon moment pour s'envoler ce serait
donc juste avant l'orage la différence
de charges qu'on appelle aussi le champ
électrique est alors à son maximum
cette force pourrait attirer vers le
haut une araignée dans le parachute
seraient remplies d'électricité statique
c'est du moins l'hypothèse mais on ne
l'avait jamais testé
la chercheuse britannique eric à mort
les a donc exposé ses araignées
uniquement un champ électrique réaction
elle déplie l'impact redresse l'abdomen
et d'écoles
sur cette vidéo on peut même
l'apercevoir monter et descendre quand
on coupe le champ électrique ou qu'on
rétabli il semble aussi que l'araignée
arrive à mesurer séparément la force du
vent est celle du champ électrique
l'équipe britannique a découvert qu'elle
a sur les parents de tous petits poils
qui frétille en présence d'électricité
c'est même poêle réagissent différemment
aux mouvements de l'air tout indique que
les araignées peuvent donc vérifier s'il
ya de l'électricité dans l'air avant se
laisser aller là où levant les portes